Campaigners say Indonesia's new morality laws, given the green light by parliament,...
...are a major setback to human rights in the world's most populous Muslim country.
The most eye-catching measure, a clause that would outlaw sex before marriage.
Now, under the law, sex outside of marriage will be punished with one year in prison,...
...although it must be reported by a family member...
...and the law will not come into effect for three years.
Unmarried people living together could face six months in jail,...
...but more broadly, spreading an ideology different to the official one,...
...could get four years in prison.
And there is a new clause against insulting the president as well.
In all, it represents,...
...a major shift in a country that's seeing growing Islamic influence in recent decades.
Our correspondent in Jakarta is Valdya Baraputri.
She's at Indonesia's parliament in Jakarta.
For sex outside of marriage, the imprisonment is maximum up to one year,...
...and for the cohabitation is up to six months.
However, the only parties who can file the complaints...
...are the spouses of these individuals who commit, now, crime or the parents.
So, as you also mentioned that this new set of laws are applied...
...not only to Indonesians, but also foreign visitors.
So, for example, is if a foreign visitor engaged in sex outside of marriage...
...with an Indonesian, then the spouse or the parents of the Indonesian...
...can file a complaint if they chose to do so.
As I said, the new set of law will take effect of maximum of three years,...
...and during that time the public can take the articles...
...they see as problematic to the Supreme Court.